PETER SZOLOVITS:
So today I'm going
to talk about
precision medicine.
And we don't really
have a very precise idea
of what precision medicine is.
And so I'm going
to start by talking
about that a little bit.
David talked about
disease subtyping.
And if you think about
how do you figure out
what are the subtypes
of a disease,
you do it by some
kind of clustering
on a bunch of different
sorts of data.
And so we have data like
demographics, comorbidities,
vital signs,
medications, procedures,
disease trajectories, whatever
those mean, image similarities.
And today, mostly I'm
going to focus on genetics.
Because this was the great hope
of the Human Genome Project,
that as we understood more
about the genetic influences
on disease, it
would help us create
precise ways of dealing
with various diseases
and figuring out the right
therapies for them and so on.
So I want to start by
reviewing a little bit
a study that was done by the
National Research Council,
so the National Academies, and
it's called "Toward Precision
Medicine."
This was fairly recent, 2017.
And they have some
interesting observations.
So they start off
and they say, well,
why is this relevant
now, when it may not
have been relevant before?
And of course, the biggie
is new capabilities
to compile molecular data
on patients on a scale that
was unimaginable 20 years ago.
So people estimated that
getting the first human genome
cost about $3 billion.
Today, getting a human genome
costs less than $1,000.
I have some figures later in
the talk showing some of the ads
that people are running.
Increasing success in
utilizing molecular information
to improve diagnosis
and treatment,
we'll talk about some of those.
Advances in IT so that we have
bigger capabilities of dealing
with so-called big data--
a perfect storm
among stakeholders
that has made them
much more receptive
to this kind of information.
So the fact that costs in the
health-care system in the US
keep rising and quality doesn't
keep rising proportionately
makes everybody
desperate to come up
with new ways of dealing
with this problem.
And so this looks like the next
great hope for how to do it.
And shifting public attitudes
toward molecular data--
so how many of you have
seen the movie Gattaca?
A few.
So that's a dystopian
view of what
happens when people are
genotyped and can therefore
be tracked by their genetics.
And it is true that there are
horror stories that can happen.
But nevertheless, people
seem to be more relaxed today
about allowing that kind of
data to be collected and used.
Because they see the potential
benefits outweighing the costs.
Not everybody--
but that continues
to be a serious issue.
So this report goes
on and says, you know,
let's think about
how to integrate
all kinds of different
data about individuals.
And they start off and
they say, you know,
one good example of this
has been Google Maps.
So Google Maps has
a coordinate system,
which is basically
longitude and latitude,
for every point on the Earth.
And they can use that
coordinate system in order
to layer on top of each other
information about postal codes,
built structures, census tracts,
land use, transportation,
everything.
And they said, wow, this
is really cool, if only we
could do this in health care.
And so their vision is to
try to do that in health care
by saying, well,
what corresponds
to latitude and longitude
is individual patients.
And these individual
patients have various kinds
of data about them,
including their microbiome,
their epigenome, their genome,
clinical signs and symptoms,
the exposome, what
are they exposed to.
And so there's
been a real attempt
to go out and create
large collections of data
that bring together all of
this kind of information.
One of those that is notable
is the Department of Health--
well, NIH basically started
a project about a year
and a half ago called All of
Us, sounds sort of menacing.
But it's really a million of us.
And they have asked institutions
around the United States
to get volunteers to
volunteer to provide
their genetic information, their
clinical data, where they live,
where they commute,
things like that,
so that they can get
environmental data about them.
And then it's meant to be an
ongoing collection of data
about a million people
who are supposed
to be a representative
sample of the United States.
So you'll see in some
of the projects I talk
about later today that
many of the studies
have been done in populations
of European ancestry.
And so they may not apply to
people of other ethnicities.
This is attempting to
sample accurately so
that the fraction of
African Americans and Asians
and Hispanics and
so on corresponds
to the sample in the
United States population.
There's a long history.
How many of you have heard of
the Framingham Heart Study?
So a lot of people.
So Framingham, in
the 1940s, agreed
to become the subject of
a long-term experiment.
I think it's now run by Boston
University, where every year
or two they go out
and they survey--
I can't remember the
number of people.
It started as something
like 50,000 people--
about their habits and
whether they smoke,
and what their
weight and height is,
and any clinical
problems they've had,
surgical procedures, et cetera.
And they've been collecting
that database now
over several generations of
people that descend from those.
And they've started collecting
genetic data as well.
So All of Us is really doing
this on a very large scale.
Now, the vision of
these of this study
was to say that we're going
to build this information
commons, which collects all
this kind of information,
and then we're going to develop
knowledge from that information
or from that data.
And that knowledge will
become the substrate on which
biomedical research can rest.
So if we find
significant associations,
then that suggests
that one should
do studies, which
will not necessarily
be answered by the data
that they've collected.
You may have to grow knock-out
mice or something in order
to test whether an
idea really works.
But this is a way
of integrating all
of that type of information.
And of course, it can
affect diagnosis, treatment,
and health outcomes, which
are the holy grail for what
you'd like to do in medicine.
Now, here's an
interesting problem.
So the focus, notice,
was on taxonomies.
So Sam Johnson was a very famous
17th century British writer.
And he built encyclopedias
and dictionaries,
and was a poet and a
reviewer and a commentator,
and did all kinds
of fancy things.
And one of his quotes
is, "My diseases
are an asthma and a dropsy
and, what is less curable,
75," years old.
So he was funny, too.
Now, if you look up
dropsy in a dictionary--
how many of you have
heard of dropsy?
A couple.
So how did you hear of it?
AUDIENCE: From
Jane Austen novels.
[LAUGHS]
PETER SZOLOVITS: Sorry?
From a novel?
AUDIENCE: Novels.
PETER SZOLOVITS: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I've heard
of dropsy [INAUDIBLE]..
PETER SZOLOVITS: Yeah.
I mean, I learned about it by
watching Masterpiece Theatre
with 19th century people, where
the grandmother would take
to her bed with the dropsy.
And it didn't turn
out well, typically.
But it took a long time
for those people to die.
So dropsy is water sickness,
swelling, edema, et cetera.
It's actually not a disease.
It's a symptom of a
whole bunch of diseases.
So it could be pulmonary
disease, heart failure,
kidney disease, et cetera.
And it's interesting.
I look back on this.
I couldn't find it for
putting together this lecture.
But at one point, I did discover
that the last time dropsy was
listed as the cause of death of
a patient in the United States
was in 1949.
So since then, it's disappeared
as a disease from the taxonomy.
And if you talk to
pulmonary people,
they suspect that
asthma, which is still
a disease in our
current lexicon,
may be very much like dropsy.
It's not a disease.
It's a symptom of a whole
bunch of underlying causes.
And the idea is
that we need to get
good enough and precise enough
at being able to figure out
what these are.
So I talked to my friend
Zack Kohane at Harvard
a few weeks ago when I started
preparing this lecture.
And he has the following idea.
And the example I'm going
to show you is from him.
So he says, well,
look, we should
have this precision
medicine modality
space, which is this
high-dimensional space that
contains all of that information
that is in the NRC report.
And then what we do is, in
this high-dimensional space,
if we're lucky, we're going
to find clusters of data.
So this always happens.
If you ever take a very
high-dimensional data set
and put it into its very
high-dimensional representation
space, it's almost
never the case
that the data is scattered
uniformly through the space.
If that were true, it
wouldn't help us very much.
But generally, it's not true.
And what you find
is that the data
tends to be on
lower-dimensional manifolds.
So it's in subsets of the space.
And so a lot of
the trick in trying
to analyze this kind
of data is figuring out
what those lower-dimensional
manifolds look like.
And often you will find among
a very large data set a cluster
of patients like this.
And then Zack's approach is to
say, well, if you're patient--
it's hard to represent
three dimensions in two.
But if you're patient that falls
somewhere in the middle of such
a cluster, then
that probably means
that they're kind of
normal for that cluster,
whereas if they fall somewhere
at the edge of such a cluster,
that probably means that
there's something odd
going on that is worth
investigating, because they're
unusual.
So then he gave me an
example of a patient of his.
And let me give you a
minute to read this.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: What's
an armamentarium?
PETER SZOLOVITS: Where
does it say armamentarium?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PETER SZOLOVITS: Oh, yeah.
So an armamentarium,
historically,
is the set of arms that
are available to an army.
So this is the set of treatments
that are available to a doctor.
AUDIENCE: Is that the
only word you don't know?
[LAUGHTER]
It's the only word--
AUDIENCE: If I start asking--
AUDIENCE: Based on [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: Oh, OK.
AUDIENCE: In the world.
Some of it, I thought
I could understand.
PETER SZOLOVITS:
Well, you probably
know what antibiotics are.
And immunosuppressants,
you've probably heard of.
Anyway, it's a bunch
of different therapies.
So this is what's
called a sick puppy.
It's a kid who is
not doing well.
They started life, at age
three, with ulcerative colitis,
which was well-controlled
by the kinds of medications
that they normally give
people with that disease.
And then all of a
sudden, 10 years later,
he breaks out with this horrible
abdominal pain and diarrhea
and blood in his stool.
And they try a bunch of stuff
that they think ought to work,
and it doesn't work.
So the kid was facing some
fairly drastic options,
like cutting out the part of
his colon that was inflamed.
So your colon is an important
part of your digestive tract.
And so losing it is not fun
and would have bad consequences
for the rest of his life.
But what they did
is they said, well,
why is he not responding
to any of these therapies?
And the difficulty,
you can imagine,
in that cloud-of-points
picture, is,
how do you figure out whether
the person is an outlier
or is in the middle of
one of these clusters,
when it depends on
a lot of things?
In this kid's case, what it
depended on most significantly
was the last six months
of his experience,
where, before, he was doing OK
with the standard treatment.
So that cloud might
have represented people
with ulcerative colitis
who were well-controlled
by the standard treatment.
And now, all of a sudden,
he becomes an outlier.
So what happened in
this case is they said,
well, maybe there
are different groups
of ulcerative colitis patients.
So maybe there are ones who
have a lifelong remission
after treatment with a commonly
used monoclonal antibody.
So that's the center
of the cluster.
Maybe there are people who
have multi-year remission
but become refractory
to these drugs.
And after other treatments, they
have to undergo a colectomy.
So that's the
removal of the colon.
And then there are people who
have, initially, a remission,
but then those
standard therapy works.
So that's what this kid
is in, this cluster.
So how do you treat this as
a machine learning problem
from the point of view
of having lots of data
about lots of
different patients?
And the challenges, of
course, include things like,
what's your distance function
in doing the kind of clustering
that people typically do?
How do you define
what an outlier is?
Because there's always a
continuum where it just
gets more and more diffuse.
What's the best representation
for time-varying data,
which is critical in this case?
What's the optimal weighting
or normalization of dimensions?
So does every dimension in this
very high-dimensional space
count the same?
Or are differences
along certain dimensions
more important than
those among others?
And does that, in fact, vary
from problem to problem?
The answer is probably yes.
So how do we find the
neighborhood for the patient?
Well, I'm going to
give you some clues
by starting with a shallow
dive into genetics.
So if you've taken a
molecular cell biology class,
this should not be news to you.
And I'm going to run
through it pretty quickly.
If you haven't,
then I hope at least
you'll pick up some
of the vocabulary.
So a wise biologist
said, "Biology
is the science of exceptions."
There are almost no rules.
About 25 years ago,
the biology department
here taught a special class
for engineering faculty
to try to explain
to us what they
were teaching in their
introductory biology,
molecular biology classes.
And I remember, I
was sitting next
to Jerry Sussman,
one of my colleagues.
And after we heard some
lecture about the 47 ways
that some theory doesn't
apply in many, many cases,
Jerry turns to me and
he says, you know,
the problem with this field is
there are just too many damned
exceptions.
There are no theories.
It's all exceptions.
And so even biologists
recognize this.
Now, people have observed,
ever since human beings walked
the earth, that
children tend to be
similar to their
parents in many ways.
And until Gregor Mendel,
this was a great mystery.
Why is it that you
are like your parents?
I mean, you must
have gotten something
from them that sort of
carries through and makes
you similar to them.
So Mendel had this
notion of having
discrete factors of inheritance,
which he called genes.
He had no idea what these were.
But conceptually, he knew
that they must exist.
And then he did a bunch of
experiments on pea plants,
showing that peas
that are wrinkled
tend to have offspring peas
that are also wrinkled.
And he worked out the
genetics of what we now
call Mendelian
inheritance, namely
dominant versus recessive
inheritance patterns.
Then Johann Miescher came
along some years later,
and he discovered a
weird thing in cells
called nuclein, which
is now known as DNA.
But it wasn't until 1952 that
Hershey and Chase said, hey,
it's DNA that is carrying
this genetic information
from generation to generation.
And then, of course,
Watson, Crick, and Franklin,
the following year, deciphered
the structure of DNA,
that it's this double
helix, and then figured out
what the mechanism
must be that allows DNA
to transmit this information.
So you have a double helix.
You match the four letters A,
C, T, G opposite each other,
and you can replicate
this DNA by splitting it
apart and growing
another strand that
is the complement
of the first one.
Now you have two.
And you can have children, pass
on this information to them.
So that was a big deal.
So a gene is defined
by the National Center
for Biotechnology Information
as a fundamental physical
and functional unit of heredity
that's a DNA sequence located
on a specific site
on a chromosome which
encodes a specific
functional product,
namely RNA or a protein.
I'll come back to
that in a minute.
The remaining mystery
is it's still very
hard to figure out what
parts of the DNA code genes.
So you would think we
might have solved this,
but we haven't quite.
And what does the rest, which
is the vast majority of the DNA,
do if it's not encoding genes?
And then, how does the
folding and the geometry,
the topology of
these structures,
influence their function?
So I went back and I read
some of Francis Crick's work
from the 1950s.
And it's very interesting.
This hypothesis was considered
controversial and tentative
at the time.
So he said, "The specificity
of a piece of nucleic acid
is expressed solely by
the sequence of its bases,
and this sequence
is a simple code
for the amino acid sequence
of a particular protein."
And there were people arguing
that he was just flat wrong,
that this was not true.
Of course, it turned
out he was right.
And then the central
dogma is the transfer
of information from nucleic
acid to nucleic acid
or from nucleic acid to
protein may be possible.
But transfer from protein
to protein or from protein
to nucleic acid is impossible.
And that's not quite true.
But it's a good
first approximation.
So this is where things stood
back about 60 years ago.
And then a few
Nobel prizes later,
we began to understand some
of the mechanism of how
this works.
And of course, how
it works is that you
have DNA, which is these
four bases, double stranded.
RNA gets produced in the
process of transcription.
So this thing unfolds.
An RNA strand is built along the
DNA and separates from the DNA,
creating a single-stranded RNA.
And then it goes and
hooks up with a ribosome.
And the ribosome takes that
RNA and takes the codes
in triplets, and
each triplet stands
for a particular amino acid,
which it then assembles
in sequence and
creates proteins, which
are sequences of amino acids.
Now, it's very complicated.
Because there's
three-dimensionality
and there's time involved.
And the rate constants--
this is chemistry, after all.
So again, a few more
Nobel prizes later,
we have that transcription,
that process of turning DNA
into RNA, is regulated
by promoter, repressor,
and enhancer regions
on the genome.
And the proteins mediate this
process by binding to the DNA
and causing the beginning
of transcription,
or causing it to run faster
or causing it to run slower,
or they interfere
with it, et cetera.
There are also these
enhancers, some of which
are very far away from
the coding region, that
make huge differences
in how much of the RNA,
and therefore how much
of the protein, is made.
And the current
understanding of that
is that, if here
is the gene, it may
be that the strand
of DNA loops around.
And the enhancer, even though
it's distant in genetic units,
is actually in close
physical proximity,
and therefore can encourage
more of this transcription
to take place.
By the way, if you're interested
in this stuff, of course
MIT teaches a lot of
courses in how to do this.
Dave Gifford and Manolis
Kellis both teach
computational courses in how
to apply computational methods
to try to decipher
this kind of activity.
So repressors prevent activator
from binding or alters
the activator in order to
change the rate constants.
And so this is
another mechanism.
Now, one of the
problems is that if you
look at the total amount of DNA
in your genes, in your cells,
only about 1 and
1/2% are exons, which
are the parts that code for
mRNA, and eventually protein.
So the question is what does
the other 98 and 1/2% do?
There was this unfortunate
tendency in the biology
community to call
that junk DNA, which
of course is a terrible notion.
Because evolution would
certainly have gotten
rid of it if it was truly junk.
Because our cells spend a lot
of energy building this stuff.
And every time a
cell divides, it
rebuilds all that
so-called junk DNA.
So it can't possibly be junk.
But the question
is, what does it do?
And we don't really
know for a lot of it.
So there are introns--
I'll show you a picture.
There are segments of the
coding region that don't wind up
as part of the RNA.
They're spliced out.
And we don't quite know why.
There are these
regulatory sequences,
which is only about 5%,
that are those promoters
and repressors and enhancers
that I talked about.
And then there's a whole
bunch of repetitive DNA that
includes transposable
elements, related sequences.
And mostly, we don't
understand what it all does.
Hypotheses are things
like, well, maybe
it's a storehouse of
potentially useful DNA
so that if environmental
conditions change a lot,
then the cell doesn't
have to reinvent
the stuff from scratch.
It saved it from previous
times in evolution
when that may have been useful.
But that's pretty much pure
speculation at this point.
So just recently,
the Killian Lecture
was given by Gerald Fink,
who's a geneticist here.
And his claim is that a gene
is not any segment of DNA
that produces RNA or protein.
But it's any segment of
DNA that is transcribed
into RNA that has some
function, whatever
it is, not necessarily building
proteins, but just anything.
And I think that view
is becoming accepted.
So I promised you a little
bit of more complexity.
So when you look at
your DNA in eukaryotes,
like us, here's the promoter.
And then here is the
sequence of the genome.
When this gets transcribed, it
gets transcribed into something
called pre-mRNA, messenger RNA.
And then there's this process
of alternative splicing
that splices out the introns
and leaves only the exons.
But sometimes it doesn't
leave all the exons.
It only leaves some of them.
And so the same gene can,
under various circumstances,
produce different
mRNA, which then
produces different proteins.
And again, there's a lot
of mysteries about exactly
how all this works.
Nevertheless, that's
the basic mechanism.
And then here, I've
just listed a few
of the complexity problems.
So there are things like,
RNA can turn into DNA.
This is a trick that
viruses use a lot.
They incorporate
themselves into your cell,
create a DNA
complement to the RNA,
and then use that to
generate more viruses.
So this is very typical
of a viral infection.
Prions, we also don't
understand very well.
This is like mad cow disease,
where these proteins are able
to cause changes in other
proteins without going through
the RNA/DNA-mediated mechanisms.
There are
DNA-modifying proteins,
the most important of
which is the stuff involved
in CRISPR-CAS9, which is
this relatively new discovery
about how bacteria are able to
use a mechanism that they stole
from viruses to edit the genetic
complement of themselves,
and more importantly, of other
viruses that attack them.
So it's an antiviral
defense mechanism.
And we're now figuring out how
to use it to do gene editing.
You may have read about this
Chinese guy who actually went
out and edited the genome of a
couple of girls who were born
in China, incorporating
some, I think, resistance
against HIV infections
in their genome.
And of course, this is
probably way too early
to do experiments
on human beings,
because they haven't
demonstrated that this is safe.
But maybe that'll
become accepted.
George Church at Harvard
has been going around--
he likes to rattle
people's chains.
And he's been going
around saying, well,
the guy, he was unethical and
was a slob, but what he's doing
is a really great idea.
So we'll see where that goes.
And then there are
these retrotransposons,
where pieces of DNA in
eukarya just pop out
of wherever they are
and insert themselves
in some other place
in the genome.
And in plants,
this happens a lot.
So for example, wheat seems to
have a huge number of copies
of DNA segments that
maybe it had only one of,
but it's replicated
through this mechanism.
Last bit of complexity--
so we have various kinds of RNA.
There's long
non-coding RNA, which
seems to participate
in gene regulation.
There is RNA interference,
that there are these small RNA
pieces that will actually
latch onto the RNA produced
by the standard
genetic mechanism
and prevent it from being
translated into protein.
This was another Nobel
Prize a few years ago.
Almost everything in this
field, if you're first,
you get a Nobel Prize for it.
Once the proteins
are made, they're
degraded differentially.
So there are
different mechanisms
in the cell that destroy
certain kinds of proteins
much faster than others.
And so the production
rate doesn't tell you
how much is going to be
there at any particular time.
And then there's this secondary
and tertiary structure,
where there's actually--
what is it?
It's a mile of DNA in
each of your cells.
So it wouldn't fit.
And so it gets wrapped up
on these acetylated histones
to produce something
called chromatin.
And again, we don't quite
understand how this all works.
Because you'd think that if
you wrap stuff up like this,
it would become inaccessible
to transcription.
And therefore, it's not
clear how it gets expressed.
But somehow or other, the
cell is able to do that.
So there's a lot yet
to learn in this area.
Now, the reason we're
interested in all this
is because, if you plot Moore's
law for how quickly computers
are becoming cheaper
per performance,
and you plot the cost
of gene sequencing,
it keeps going down.
And it goes down much faster
even than Moore's law.
So this is pretty remarkable.
And it means that, as I said,
that $3 dollar first genome now
costs just a few
hundred dollars.
In fact, if you're just
interested in the whole exome,
so only the 2%,
roughly, of the DNA that
produces genetic
coding, you can now
go to this company, which
I have nothing to do with.
I just pulled this off the web.
But for $299, they will
give you 50-times coverage
on about six gigabases.
And if you pay
them an extra $100,
they'll do it at 100x coverage.
So these techniques
are very noisy.
And so it's important to
get lots of replicates
in order to reassemble
what you think is going on.
A slightly more recent
phenomenon is people say, well,
not only can we
sequence your DNA
but we can sequence the RNA that
got transcribed from the DNA.
And in fact, you can buy a
kit for $360 that will take
the RNA from individual cells--
so these are like
picoliter amounts of stuff.
And it will give you the RNA
sequence for $360 for up to 100
cells, so $3, $3.50 per cell.
So people are very excited.
And there are now also
companies that will
sell you advanced analysis.
So they will correlate
the data that you
are getting with
different databases
and figure out whether
this represents
a dominant or a recessive
or an x-linked model,
if you have family familial
data and functional annotation
of candidate genes, et cetera.
And so, for example, starting
about three years ago,
if you walk into the Dana-Farber
with a newly diagnosed cancer,
a solid-tumor cancer, they will
take a sample of that cancer,
send it off to companies
like this, or their own labs,
and do sequencing and do
analysis and try to figure out
exactly which damaged genes
that you have may be causing
the cancer, and maybe more
importantly, since it's still
a pretty empirical field, which
unusual variants of your genes
suggest that certain
drugs are likely to be
more effective in treating
your cancer than other drugs.
So this has become completely
routine in cancer care
and in a few other domains.
So now I'm going to switch to a
more technical set of material.
So if you want to
characterize disease subtypes
using gene expression
arrays, microarrays, here's
one way to do it.
And this is a famous
paper by Alizadeh.
It was essentially the first
of this class of papers
back in 2001, I think.
Yeah, 2001.
And since then, there have
been probably tens or hundreds
of thousands of other
papers published
doing similar kinds of
analyses on other data sets.
So what they did is
they said, OK, we're
going to extract the coding RNA.
We're going to create
complementary DNA from it.
We're going to use a
technique to amplify that,
because we're starting
with teeny-tiny quantities.
And then we're going to take
a microarray, which is either
a glass slide with tens
or hundreds of thousands
of spotted bits of
DNA on it or it's
a silicon chip with
wells that, again,
have tens or hundreds of
thousands of bits of DNA in it.
Now, where does
that DNA come from?
Initially, it was just
a random collection
of pieces of genes
from the genome.
Since then, they've gotten
somewhat more sophisticated.
But the idea is that I'm going
to take the amplified cDNA,
I'm going to mark with one of
these jellyfish proteins that
glows under light,
and then I'm going
to flow it over this slide
or over this set of wells.
And the complementary parts
of the complementary DNA
will stick to the samples of
DNA that are in this well.
OK-- stands to reason.
An alternative is that you
take normal tissue as well
as, say, the cancerous tissue,
you mark the normal tissue
with green fluorescent
jellyfish stuff
and you mark the
cancer with red,
and then you flow both
of them in equal amounts
over the array.
That lets you measure a ratio.
And you don't have as much
of a calibration problem
about trying to figure
out the exact value.
And then you cluster
these samples by nearness
in the expression space.
And you cluster the genes
by expression similarity
across samples.
So it used to be
called bi-clustering.
And I'll talk in a few minutes
about a particular technique
for doing this.
So this is a typical
microarray experiment.
The RNA is turned into
its complementary DNA,
flowed over the microarray chip.
And you get out a
bunch of spots that
are to various degrees
of green and red.
And then you
calculate their ratio.
And then you do
this bi-clustering.
And what you get is a
hierarchical clustering
of genes and a hierarchical
clustering, in their case,
of breast cancer biopsy
specimens that express
these genes in different ways.
So this was pretty
revolutionary,
because the answers made sense.
So when they did
this on 19 cell lines
in 65 breast tumor samples
and a whole bunch of genes,
they came up with a
clustering that said, hmm,
it looks like there are
some samples that have
this endothelial cell cluster.
So it's a particular
kind of problem.
And you could correlate
it with pathology
from the tumor slides
and different subclasses.
And then this is a very
typical kind of heat map
that you see in
this type of study.
Another study from 65
breast carcinoma samples,
using the gene list that
they curated before,
looks like it clusters
the expression levels
into these five clusters.
It's a little hard to look at.
I mean, when I stare at
these, it's not obvious to me
why the mathematics came up with
exactly those clusters rather
than some others.
But you can see that
there is some sense to it.
So here you see a lot of
greens at this end of it
and not very much at
this end, and vise versa.
So there is some difference
between these clusters.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: How did they
come up with the gene list?
And does anyone ever do this
kind of cluster analysis
without coming up with
a gene list first?
PETER SZOLOVITS: Yes.
So I'm going to talk in a
minute about modern gene-wide
association studies,
where basically you
say, I'm going to look at
every gene known to man.
So they still have a list, but
the list is 20,000 or 25,000.
It's whatever we know about.
And that's another
way of doing it.
So what was compelling about
this work, this group's work,
is a later analysis showed that
these five subtypes actually
had different survival rates,
and at p-equal 0.01 level
of statistical significance.
You've seen these survival
curves, of course,
before from David's lecture.
But this is pretty impressive
that doing something
that had nothing to do
with the clinical condition
of the patient--
this is purely based on their
gene expression levels--
you were able to find
clusters that actually
behave differently, clinically.
So some of them do
better than others.
So this paper and
this approach to work
set off a huge set
of additional work.
This was, again, back
in the Alizadeh paper.
They did a similar
relationship between 96 samples
of normal and
malignant lymphocytes.
And they get a
similar result, where
the clusters that
they identify here
correspond to sort of
well-understood existing
types of lymphoma.
So this, again, gives
you some confidence
that what you're extracting
from these genetic correlations
is meaningful in the terms that
people who deal with lymphomas
think about, about the topic.
But of course, it can
give you much more detail.
Because people's
intuitions may not
be as effective as these
large-scale data analyses.
So to get to your question
about generalizing this,
I mean, here's one way
that I look at this.
If I list all the genes and
I list all the phenotypes--
now, we're a little
more sure of what
the genes are than of
what the phenotypes are.
So that's an
interesting problem.
Then I can do a
bunch of analyses.
So what is a phenotype?
Well, it can be a diagnosed
disease, like breast cancer.
Or it can be the type of
lymphoma from the two examples
I've just shown you.
It can also be a qualitative
or a quantitative trait.
It could be your weight.
It could be your eye color.
It could be almost anything that
is clinically known about you.
And it could even be behavior.
It could be things like, what
is your daily output of Twitter
posts?
That's a perfectly
reasonable trait.
I don't know if it's
genetically predictable.
But you'll see some
surprising things that are.
So then, how do
you analyze this?
Well, if you start by looking
at a particular phenotype
and say, what genes are
associated with this,
then you're doing what's
called a GWAS, or a Gene-Wide
Association Study.
So you look for
genetic differences
that correspond to specific
phenotypic differences.
And usually, you're looking at
things like single nucleotide
polymorphisms.
So this is places where
your genome differs
from the reference genome,
the most common genome
in the human population,
at one particular locus.
So you have a C instead of
a G or something one place
in your genes.
Copy number variations,
there are stretches of DNA
that have repeats in them.
And the number of
repeats is variable.
So one of the most
famous ones of these
is the one associated
with Huntington's disease.
It turns out that if you have
up to 20-something repeats
of a certain section of DNA,
you're perfectly healthy.
But if you're
above 30 something,
then you're going to die
of Huntington's disease.
And again, we don't quite
understand these mechanisms.
But these are empirically known.
So copy number
variations are important,
gene expression levels, which
I've talked about a minute ago.
But the trick here
in a GWAS is to look
at a very wide set
of genes rather than
just a limited set
of samples that you
know you're interested in.
Now, the other approach
is the opposite,
which is to say, let's
look at a particular gene
and figure out what's
it correlated with.
And so that's called a PheWAS, a
Phenome-Wide Association Study.
And now what you do is you list
all the different phenotypes.
And you say, well, we can
do the same kind of analysis
to say which of them
are disproportionately
present in people who
have that genetic variant.
So here's what a
typical GWAS looks like.
This is called a Manhattan plot,
which I think is pretty funny.
But it does kind of look like
the skyline of Manhattan.
So this is all of your
genes laid out in sequence
along your chromosomes.
And you take a particular
phenotype and you
say, what is the difference
in the ratio of expression
levels between people who have
this disease and people who
don't have this disease?
And something like this gene,
whatever it is, clearly there
is an enormous difference
in its expression level.
And so you would be surprised if
this gene didn't have something
to do with the disease.
And similarly, you can calculate
different significance levels.
You have to do something
like a Bonferroni correction,
because you are testing so
many hypotheses simultaneously.
And so typically, the
top of these lines
is the Bonferroni-corrected
threshold.
And then you say, OK, this guy,
this guy, this guy, this guy,
and this guy come
above that threshold.
So these are good
candidate genes
to think that may be
associated with this disease.
Now, can you go out and start
treating people based on that?
Well, it's probably
not a good idea.
Because there are many
reasons why this analysis
might have failed.
All the lessons that you've
heard about confounders
come in very strongly here.
And so typically,
what biologists
do is they do this
kind of analysis.
They then create a
strain of knock-out mice
who have some analog
of whatever disease
it is that you're studying.
And they see whether,
in fact, knocking out
a certain gene, like this
guy, cures or creates
the disease that you're
interested in in this mouse
model.
And then you have a more
mechanistic explanation
for what the
relationship might be.
So basically, you're
looking at the ratio
of the odds of having the
disease if you have a SNP,
or if you have a genetic
variant, to having the disease
if you don't have
the genetic variant.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: I'm just
curious on the class size.
It seems like the
Bonferroni correction
is being very limiting here,
potentially conservative.
And I'm curious if there
are specific computational
techniques adapted
to this scenario that
allow you to sort of mine a bit
more effectively than those.
PETER SZOLOVITS: Yeah.
So if you talk to the
statisticians, who
are more expert at this than the
computer scientists typically,
they will tell you
that Bonferroni
is a very conservative
kind of correction.
And if you can impose
some sort of structure
on the set of genes that you're
testing, then you can cheat.
And you can say, well, you
know, these 75 genes actually
are all part of
the same mechanism.
And we're really testing
the mechanism and not
the individual gene.
And therefore, instead of
making a Bonferroni correction
for 75 of these guys, we
only have to do it for one.
And so you can reduce the
Bonferroni correction that way.
But people get nervous
when you do that.
Because your incentive
as a researcher
is to show statistically
significant results.
But that whole
question of p-values
keeps coming under discussion.
So the head of the American
Statistical Association,
about 15 years ago-- he's
the Stanford professor.
And he published what became a
very notorious article saying,
you know, we got it all wrong.
Statistical significance
is not significance
in the standard English
sense of the word.
And so he called for
various other ways
and was more sympathetic to
Bayesian kinds of reasoning
and things like that.
So there may be some
gradual movement to that.
But this is a huge can of
worms to which we don't have
a very good mechanistic answer.
All right.
So if you do these GWASs--
and this is the real
problem with them
is that most of what
you see is down here.
So you have things
with common variants.
But they have very
small effect sizes
when you look at
what their effect is
on a particular disease.
And so that same Zach Kohane
that I mentioned earlier
has always been challenging
people doing this kind of work,
saying, look--
for example, we did
a GWAS with Kat Liao,
who was a guest interviewee
here when I was lecturing
earlier in the semester.
She's a rheumatologist.
And we did a gene-wide
association study.
We found a bunch of genes
that had odds ratios
of like 1.1 to 1, 1.2 to 1.
And they're statistically
significant.
Because if you
collect enough data,
everything is
statistically significant.
But are they significant in the
other sense of significance?
Well, so Zach's
argument was that if you
look at something like the
odds ratio of lung cancer
for people who do
and don't smoke,
the odds ratios is eight.
So when you compare 1.1 to
eight, you should be ashamed.
You're not doing very well
in terms of elucidating
what the effects really are.
And so Zack actually
has argued very strongly
that rather than focusing
all our attention
on these genetic factors that
have very weak relationships,
we should instead focus
more on clinical things that
often have stronger
predictive relationships.
And some combination,
of course, is best.
Now, it is true that we know a
whole bunch of highly penetrant
Mendelian mutations.
So these are ones where,
one change in your genome,
and all of a sudden you
have some terrible disease.
And I think when the Genome
Project started in the 1990s,
there was an expectation
that we would
find a whole bunch
more things like that
from knowing the genome.
And that expectation was dashed.
Because what we discovered
is that our predecessors
were actually pretty
good at recognizing
those kinds of
diseases, from Mendel
on, with the wrinkled peas.
If you see a family in
which there's a segregation
pattern where you can
see who has the disease
and who doesn't and what
their relationships are,
you can get a pretty
good idea of what
genes or what
genetic variants are
associated with that disease.
And it turns out we had
found almost all of them.
And so there weren't a whole lot
more that are highly penetrant
Mendelian mutations.
And so what we had is
mostly these common variants
with small effects.
What's really interesting
and worth working on
is these rare variants
with small effects.
So the mystery kid, like the
kid whose case I showed you,
probably has some
interesting genetics
that is quite uncommon, and
obviously, for a long time,
had a small effect.
But then all of a sudden,
something happened.
And there is this whole
field called unknown disease
diagnosis that says, what do
you do when some weirdo walks in
off the street and you have
no idea what's going on?
And there are now companies--
so I was a judge in a challenge
about four or five
years ago, where
we took eight kids like
this and we genotyped them,
and we genotyped their
parents and their grandparents
and their siblings.
And we took all
their clinical data.
This was with the consent
of their parents, of course.
And we made it
available as a contest.
And we had 20-something
participants
from around the world who
tried to figure out something
useful to say about these kids.
And you go through a pipeline.
And we did this in two rounds.
The first round, the pipelines
all looked very different.
And the second round,
a couple of years
later, the pipelines had
pretty much converged.
And I see now that there
is a company that did well
in one of these challenges that
now sells this as a service,
like I showed you before,
different company.
And so you send them
the genetic makeup
of some kid with
a weird condition
and the genetic makeup
of their family,
and it tries to
guess which genes
might be involved in causing
the problem that this child has.
That's not the
answer, of course.
Because that's just a sort
of suspicion of a problem.
And then you have to go out
and do real biological work
to try to reproduce
that scenario
and see what the
effects really are.
But at least in a couple of
cases out of those eight,
those hints have, in fact, led
to a much better understanding
of what caused the
problems in these children.
That was fun, by the way.
I got my name as
an author on one
of these things that looks
like a high-energy physics
experiment.
The first two pages of the paper
is just the list of authors.
So it's kind of interesting.
Now, here's a more
recent study, which
is a gene-wide association
of type 2 diabetes.
It's not quite
gene-wide, because they
didn't study every locus.
But they studied a
hundred loci that
have been associated with type
2 diabetes in previous studies.
So of course, if you're
not the first person doing
this kind of work, you can
rely on the literature, where
other people have already come
up with some interesting ideas.
So they wound up
selecting 94 type
2 diabetes-associated variants.
So these are the glycemic
traits, fasting insulin,
fasting glucose, et cetera;
things about your body,
your body mass index, height,
weight, circumference,
et cetera; lipid levels
of various sorts,
associations with
different diseases,
coronary artery disease,
renal function, et cetera.
And let me come back to this.
So what they did
is they said, OK,
here's the way we're
going to model this.
We have an association
matrix that
has 47 traits by
94 genetic factors.
So we make a matrix out of that.
And then they did
something funny.
So they doubled the traits.
The technology for
matrix factorization
is called non-negative
matrix factorization.
And since many of
those associations
were negative, what they
did is, for each trait
that had both positive
and negative values,
they duplicated the column.
They created one column that had
positive associations and one
column that had the negation
of the negative associations
with zeros everywhere else.
So that's how they
dealt with that problem.
And then they said,
OK, we're going
to apply matrix
factorization to factor X
into two matrices, W and H. And
I drew those here on the board.
So you have one matrix that--
well, this is your
original 47 by 94 matrix.
And the question is, can you
find two smaller matrices that
are 47 by K and K by 94,
that when you multiply these
together, you get back
some close approximation
to that matrix.
Now, if you've been
looking at the literature,
there are all kinds of
ideas like auto-encoders.
And these are all basically
the same underlying idea.
It's an unsupervised
method that says,
can we find interesting
patterns in the data
by doing some kind of
dimension reduction?
And this is one of those methods
for doing dimension reduction.
So what's nice about
this one is that when
they get their W and H,
they predict X from that.
And then they know, of
course, what the error is.
And they say, well, minimizing
that error is our objective.
So that also lets them
get at the question of,
what's the right K?
And that's an important problem.
Because normally
clustering methods
like hierarchical
clustering, you
have to specify what
the number of clusters
is that you're looking for.
And that's hard to do a
priori, whereas this technique
can suggest at least which
one fits the data best.
And so the loss function is
some regularized L2 distance
between the reconstruction, W
times H and X, and some penalty
terms based on the
size of W and H
coupled by these
relevance weights that--
you can look at the paper, which
I think I referred to in here
and I asked you to read.
And then they do give
sampling and a whole bunch
of computational tricks
to speed up the process.
So they got about 17,000 people
from four different studies.
They're all of
European ancestry.
So there's the usual
generalization problem of,
how do you apply this to people
from other parts of the world?
And they did
individual-level analysis
of all the individuals with
type 2 diabetes from these.
And the results were that
they found five subtypes--
again, five-- which were
present on 82.3% of iterations.
By the way, total
random aside, there's
a wonderful video at
Caltech of the woman who
just made the picture of
the black hole shadow.
And she makes arguments
very much like this.
We tried a whole bunch
of different ways
of coming up with this picture.
And what we decided
was true is whatever
showed up in almost all
of the different methods
of reconstructing it.
So this is kind of
a similar argument.
And their interpretations,
medically, are that one of them
is involved with variations
in the beta cells.
So these are the cells in your
pancreas that make insulin.
One of them is in
variations in proinsulin,
which is a predecessor
of insulin that
is under different controls.
And then three others have to
do with obesity, bad things
about your lipid metabolism,
and then your liver function.
And if you look
at their results,
the top spider diagrams, so
the way to interpret these
is that the middle
circle, octagon,
the one in the very middle,
is the one with negative data.
The one in between
that and the outside
is with zero correlation.
And the outside one is
with positive correlation.
And what you see is
that different factors
have different influences
in these different clusters.
So these are the
factors that are
most informative in figuring out
which cluster somebody belongs
to.
And they indeed look
considerably different.
I'm not going to
have you read this.
But it'll be in the slides.
Now, one thing
that's interesting--
and again, this won't
be on the final exam.
But look at these numbers.
They're all tiny.
Some of them are hugely
statistically significant.
So DI, whatever that is,
contributes 0.05 units
to having beta-cell type of
this disease at a p-value of 6.6
times 10 to the minus 37th.
So it's definitely there.
It's definitely an effect.
But it's not a very big effect.
And what strikes me every
time I look at studies
like this is just how
small those effects are,
whether you're
predicting some output
like the level of
insulin in the patient,
or whether you're predicting
something like a category
membership, as in this table.
So as I said, PheWAS
is a reverse GWAS.
And the first paper that
introduced the terminology
was by Josh Denny and colleagues
at Vanderbilt in 2010.
And so they did not quite
a phenome-wide association.
But they said, we're going
to take 25,000 samples
from the Vanderbilt
biobank, and we're
going to take the first
6,000 European Americans
with samples, no other
criteria for selection.
Why European Americans?
Because all the GWAS data
is about European Americans.
So they wanted to be
able to compare to that.
And then they said,
let's pick not
one SNP but five different
SNPs that we're interested in.
So they picked these,
which are known
to be associated with
coronary artery disease
and carotid artery stenosis,
atrial fibrillation,
multiple sclerosis and
lupus, rheumatoid arthritis
and Crohn's disease.
So it's a nice grab-bag
of interesting disease
associations.
And then the hard
work they did was
they went through
the tens of thousands
of different billing
codes that were available.
And they, by hand, clustered
them into 744 case groups
and said, OK, these
are the phenotypes
that we're interested in.
And that data set, by the
way, is still available.
And it's been used by
a lot of other people,
because nobody wants to
repeat that analysis.
So now what you see
is something very
similar to what you saw in
GWAS, except here, what we
have is the ICD-9 code group.
I guess by the time this got
published, it was up to 1,000.
And these are the same
kinds of odds ratios
for the genetic expression
of those markers.
And what you find, again, is
that this is the p-equal 0.05.
That's the
Bonferroni-corrected version.
And only multiple
sclerosis comes up
for this particular SNP,
which was one of the ones
that they expected to come up.
But they were interested to
see what else lights up when
you do this sort of analysis.
And what they discovered
is that malignant neoplasm
of the rectum, benign
digestive tract neoplasms--
so there's something going on
about cancer that is somehow
related to this
single-nucleotide polymorphism,
not at a statistically
high enough level,
but it's still
kind of intriguing
that there may be some
relationship there.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So is this
data at all public?
Or is this at one
particular hospital?
Or who has this data?
Would it be combined?
PETER SZOLOVITS: Yeah.
I don't believe that you
can get their data unless--
I think, if--
I mean, they're pretty
good about collaborating
with people.
So if you're willing
to become a volunteer
employee at Vanderbilt, they
could probably take you.
But I just made that up.
But every hospital has
very strong controls.
Now, what is
available is the NCBI
has GEO, the Gene
Expression Omnibus, which
has enormous amounts--
like, I think, hundreds of
billions of sample data.
But you don't often know
exactly what the sample is from.
So it comes with
an accession number
and an English description
of what kind of data it is.
And there are actually
lots of papers
where people have
done natural language
processing on those English
descriptions in order
to try to figure out what
kind of data this is.
And then they can
make use of it.
So you can be clever.
And there's a ton
of data out there,
but it's not well-curated data.
Now, what's interesting
is you don't always
get what you expect.
So for example, that
SNP was selected
because it's thought
to be associated
with multiple
sclerosis and lupus.
But in reality, the association
with lupus is not significant.
Its p-value of 0.5, which
is not very impressive.
The association with multiple
sclerosis is significant.
And so they found, in
this particular study,
a couple of things that had been
expected but didn't work out.
So for example, this SNP, which
was associated with coronary
artery disease and thought to
be associated with this carotid
plaque deposition in your
carotid artery, just isn't.
p-value of 0.82 is
not impressive at all.
OK, onward.
So that was done for SNPs.
Now, a very popular
idea today is
to look at expression levels,
partly because of those prices
I showed you where you can
very cheaply get expression
levels from lots of samples.
And so there's this whole notion
of Expression Quantitative
Trait Loci, or EQTL,
that says, hey,
instead of working as hard
as the Vanderbilt guys did
to figure out these hundreds
of categories of disease,
let's just take your
gene expression levels
and use those as defining the
trait that we're interested in.
So now we're looking
at the relationship
between your genome and
the expression levels.
And so you might say, well,
that ought to be easy.
Because if the gene is there,
it's going to get expressed.
But of course, that's
not telling you
whether the gene is being
activated or repressed
or enhanced, or whether any
of these other complications
that I talked about
earlier are present.
And so this is an interesting
empirical question.
And so people say, well, maybe
a small genetic variation
will cause different
expression levels of some RNA.
And we can measure
these, and then
use those to do this
kind of analysis.
So differential expression
in different populations--
there is evidence
that, for example,
if you take 16 people
of African descent,
then 17% of the genes
in a small sample
of 16 people differ in
their expression level
among those individuals;
and similarly,
26% in this Asian population and
17% to 29% in a HapMap sample.
Of course, some of
these differences
may be because of
confounders like environment,
different tissues, limited
correlation of these expression
levels to disease phenotypes.
Nevertheless, this
type of analysis
has uncovered relationships
between these EQTLs and asthma
and Crohn's disease.
So I'll let you read
the conclusion of one
of these studies.
So this is saying what I said
before, that we probably know
all the Mendelian diseases.
So the diseases that we're
interested in understanding
better today are the ones
that are not Mendelian,
but they're some complicated
combination of effects
from different genes.
And that makes it, of course,
a much harder problem.
There is an interesting
recent paper--
well, not that recent--
2005-- that uses Bayesian
network technology
to try to get at this.
And so they say, well, if you
have some quantitative trait
locus and you treat the
RNA expression level
as this expression quantitative
trait locus, and then
you take C as some complex
trait, which might be a disease
or it might be a
proclivity for something,
or it might be one of
Josh Denny's categories
or whatever, then
there are a number
of different Bayesian
network-style models that you
can build.
So you can say, ah,
the genetic variant
causes a difference in
gene expression, which
in turn causes the disease.
Or you could say,
hmm, the genetic trait
causes the disease,
which in turn causes
the observable difference
in gene expression.
Or you can say that the
genetic variant causes
both the expression
level and the disease,
but they're not
necessarily coupled.
So they may be
conditionally independent
given the genetic variant.
Or you can have
more complex issues,
like you could have the
gene causing changes
in expression level of a
whole bunch of different RNA,
which combined
cause some disease.
Or you can have
different genetic changes
all impacting the expression
of some RNA, which
causes the disease.
Or-- just wait for it.
Oops.
You can have models
like this that say,
we have some environmental
contributions
and a bunch of
different genes which
affect the expression of a
bunch of different EQTLs, which
cause a bunch of
clinical traits, which
cause changes in a bunch
of reactive RNA, which
cause comorbidities.
So the approach
that they take is
to say, well, we can generate
a large set of hypotheses
like this, and
then just calculate
the likelihood of the data
given each of these hypotheses.
And whichever one assigns the
greatest likelihood to the data
is most likely to be the
one that's close to correct.
So let me just blast through
the rest of this quickly.
Scaling up genome-phenome
association studies--
the UK Biobank is sort of
like this All of Us project.
But they do make
their data available.
All of Us will, also, but it
hasn't been collected yet.
UK Biobank has
about half a million
de-identified individuals
with full exome sequencing,
although they only have about
10% of what they want now.
And many of them will have worn
24-hour activity monitors so
that we have behavioral data.
Some of them have had
repeat measurements.
They do online questionnaires.
About a fifth of them
will have imaging.
And it's linked to their
electronic health record.
So we know if they
died or if they
had cancer or various
hospital episodes, et cetera.
And there's a website here which
publishes the latest analyses.
And so you see, on April
18, genetic variants that
protect against obesity and
type 2 diabetes discovered,
moderate with meat-eaters
are at risk of bowel cancer,
and research identifies
genetic causes of poor sleep.
So this is all over the place.
But these are all the studies
that are being done by this.
I'll skip this.
But there's a group here
at MGH and the Broad that
is using this data
to do, large-scale,
many, many gene-wide
association studies.
And one of the things
that I promised you,
which is interesting, is
from these studies, they say,
well, the heritability
of height is pretty good.
It's about 0.46 with a p-value
of 10 to the minus 109th.
So your height is definitely
determined, in large part,
by your parents' height.
But what's interesting
is that whether you
get a college degree
or not is determined
by whether your parents got
a college degree or not.
This is probably not genetic.
Or it's only partly genetic.
But it clearly has confounders
us from money and social status
and various things like that.
And then what I found
amusing is that even
TV-watching is partly
heritable from your genetics.
Fortunately, my parents
watch a lot of TV.
The last thing I
wanted to mention,
but I'm not going to
have time to get into it,
is this notion of gene
set enrichment analysis.
It's what I was saying
before, that genes typically
don't act by themselves.
And so if you think back
on high school biology,
you probably learned
about the Krebs cycle
that powers cellular mechanisms.
So if you break any
part of that cycle,
your cells don't
get enough energy.
And so it stands to
reason that if you
want to understand that
sort of metabolism,
you shouldn't be looking
at an individual gene.
But you should be looking
at all of the genes that
are involved in that process.
And so there have been many
attempts to try to do this.
The Broad Institute here has
a set of, originally, 1,300
biologically-defined gene sets.
So these were ones that
interacted with each other
in controlling some important
mechanism in the body.
They're now up to 18,000.
For example, genes involved
in oxidative phosphorylation
and muscle tissue show reduced
expression in diabetics,
although the average decrease
per gene is only 20%.
So they have these sets.
And from those, there
is a very nice technique
that is able to pull--
it's essentially a
way of strengthening
the gene-wide associations by
allowing you to associate them
with these sets of genes.
And the approach that
they take is quite clever.
They say, if we take all
the genes in a gene set
and we order them by their
correlation with whatever trait
we're interested
in, then the genes
that are closer to
the beginning of that
are more likely to be involved.
Because they're the ones that
are most strongly associated.
And so they have this
random walk process
that find sort of the
maximum place where
you can say anything
before that is
likely to be associated
with the disease
that you're interested in.
And they've had a number of
successes of showing enrichment
in various diseases and
various biological factors.
The last thing I want to say
is a little bit disappointing.
I was just really looking
for the killer paper
to talk about that
uses some really
sophisticated deep
learning, machine learning.
And as far as I can tell,
it doesn't exist yet.
So most of these methods are
based on clustering techniques
on clever ideas,
like the one for gene
set enrichment analysis.
But they're not neural
network types of techniques.
They're not immensely
sophisticated.
So what you see coming up is
things like Bayesian networks
and clustering and matrix
factorization and so on, which
sort of sound like 10-, 15-,
20-year-old technologies.
And I haven't seen examples
yet of the hot off the presses,
we built a 83-layer
neural network
that outperforms
these other methods.
I suspect that that's coming.
It just hasn't hit
yet, as far as I know.
If you know of such papers,
by all means, let me know.
All right.
Thank you.